Amy Duggar tells et she was devastated  to find out about her parents divorce  amy king whose maiden name is Duggar  reveals her parents are splitting after  nine years of marriage she tells ET  quote the divorce papers came and my dad  told me through a text on christmas i  don't think he meant to he just didn't  know what to do I was devastated it hit  me so hard that night Amy says her mom  came over and they watched Christmas  movies and quote had such a special time  to make her smile in court documents  obtained by et Amy's father claims they  separated on December 20th due to his  wife's quote intolerable treatment Amy  says her parents had an on-again  off-again relationship for quite a long  time now amy is trying to focus on her  life as a newlywed she and her husband  Dylan King tied the knot in September  for Christmas Dylan surprised Amy with a  Honda HRV  and a rescue kid